LET'S BRING IN CNN CHIEF
NATIONAL CORRESPONDENT AND
ANCHOR OF "INSIDE POLITICS" JOHN
KING AND CNN SENIOR POLITICAL
COMMENTATOR AND FORMER SENIOR
ADVISER TO PRESIDENT OBAMA,
DAVID AXELROD, HOST OF "THE AX
FI
FILES."
IT IS GOOD TO HAVE YOU BOTH.
LET'S GET YOUR TAKEAWAYS,
TOPLINE, JOHN KING, LET'S START
WITH KANSAS.
HOW SURPRISED ARE YOU?
>> WELL, SURPRISED THAT I GUESS
IN SOME WAYS, BUT I THINK, LOOK,
THE PILLAR OF A DEMOCRACY IS
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO LISTEN TO THE
PEOPLE.
COMMON SENSE CONSERVATIVES IN
THE MIDDLE OF AMERICA
ESSENTIALLY SAID TO THE
REPUBLICAN POLITICIANS, WHOA,
SLOW DOWN.
WE HAVE SEEN POLLING FOR A LONG
TIME THAT MAJORITY SUPPORTED ROE
V. WADE.
THIS IS NOT KANSAS SAYING WE
WANT TO ALLOW ALL ABORTIONS.
THIS IS KANSAS SAYING WE
DISAGREE WITH THE SUPREME COURT
AND WE WANT THE POLITICIANS TO
SLOW DOWN AND LISTEN TO US.
LET'S HAVE A NUANCED,
REASONABLE, COMPROMISED DEBATE
ABOUT THIS.
IT IS ALSO PROOF IN A PRIMARY
ELECTION, A LOT OF PEOPLE TURNED
OUT.
THE DEMOCRATS BELIEVE THIS WILL
HELP THEM IN NOVEMBER, THIS WILL
MOTIVATE VOTERS.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE VOTE,
ESPECIALLY IN THE SUBURBS, THE
KANSAS CITY, KANSAS, AREA,
TOPEKA, A LOT OF PEOPLE TURNED
OUT.
REPUBLICAN WOMEN, WHO ARE LIKELY
TO VOTE REPUBLICAN IN THE FALL,
MIGHT THEY COME BACK NOW?
OPEN QUESTION.
BUT THIS WAS A SHOT TO THE
POLITICIANS TO STOP AND LISTEN
TO THE PEOPLE.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK, DAVID?
>> WELL, I AGREE WITH JOHN.
I THINK TURNOUT IS THE BIG WORD
HERE.
YOU LOOK AT A STATE LIKE
MICHIGAN, FOR EXAMPLE, WHERE
THERE IS A VERY COMPETITIVE OR
IMPORTANT AT LEAST GOVERNOR'S
RACE, THE REPUBLICANS NOMINATED
A CANDIDATE YESTERDAY WHO IS
ARDENTLY ANTI-ABORTION RIGHTS,
THERE IS AN INITIATIVE ON THE
BALLOT, ISSUE ON THE BALLOT IN
THE FALL, THAT WOULD ENSHRINE
ABORTION RIGHTS IN THE
CONSTITUTION OF MICHIGAN.
THAT COULD CHANGE THE CONTOURS
OF THAT RACE.
SO, LOOK, DEMOCRATS HAVE A LOT
OF HEAD WINDS GOING INTO THIS
ELECTION, YOU KNOW.
ECONOMIC HEAD WINDS, GENERAL
SOUR MOOD IN THE COUNTRY,
PRESIDENT'S APPROVAL RATINGS ARE
LOW, BUT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
COULD REALLY ALTER THE DYNAMIC
TO THE POINT WHERE IT MAY NOT BE
AS BAD AS DEMOCRATS FEAR.
>> LOOK, AND WE SHOULD SAY THAT
THAT DOESN'T NECESSARILY CHANGE
THE TRAJECTORY OF THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES, RIGHT?
JOHN KING, BUT, YOU KNOW, ONE OF
THE DYNAMICS WE DID SEE
PARTICULARLY IN ARIZONA IS THESE
ELECTION DENIERS WINNING THESE
CLOSE PARTISAN PRIMARIES, WE
HAVEN'T DECLARED THESE RACES BUT
THEY SEEM TO BE IN POLE
POSITION.
WE SAW CHRIS COBACH PULLING IT
OUT.
DOES THAT CREATE A POTENTIAL
PROBLEM FOR REPUBLICANS IN TERMS
OF MOTIVATING THE CENTER TO STOP
THE FAR RIGHT OR DO YOU THINK
THOSE HEAD WINDS WILL PUSH SOME
OF THESE FOLKS INTO OFFICE?
>> I THINK THAT'S A DEFINING
QUESTION, ACTUALLY, JOHN,
HEADING INTO NOVEMBER, IN SWING
STATES LIKE ARIZONA.
GEORGIA REPUBLICANS ESSENTIALLY
TOLD DONALD TRUMP IN HIS
ELECTION TO GO AWAY.
GEORGIA REPUBLICANS SAID WE'RE
GOING TO KEEP THE ESTABLISHMENT
REPUBLICANS, THE PEOPLE WHO SAID
NO TO DONALD TRUMP, WE WON'T
HELP YOU REPEAT, THAT'S GEORGIA
REPUBLICANS.
IN ARIZONA IT SOMETHING
DIFFERENT.
REPUBLICAN PARTY IS IN A BIT OF
A MESS HERE.
JOE BIDEN WON ARIZONA.
PEOPLE TALK ABOUT THE SHIFTING
OF ARIZONA.
AX KNOWS ARIZONA QUITE WELL, ARE
DEMOCRATS GOING TO SUCCEED IN
WINNING THE GOVERNORSHIP,
KEEPING THE SENATE SEAT, WINNING
STATEWIDE OFFICE?
THAT WOULD BE A BIG SHIFT IN
AMERICAN POLITICS IF DEMOCRATS
THAT QUICKLY MAKE GAINS IN A
STATE THAT HAD BEEN REPUBLICAN
FOR A LONG TIME.
IT IS AN OPEN QUESTION.
BUT IF YOU HAVE A SLATE OF
ELECTION DENIERS, IT CERTAINLY
GIVES DEMOCRATS A UNIFIED FOCUS
ON WHETHER IT IS THE SECRETARY
OF STATE'S RACE, THE SENATE RACE
OR THE RACE FOR GOVERNOR.
>> I SAID THIS BEFORE, BUT I
THINK DONALD -- IF THE DEMOCRATS
RETAIN THE SENATE THIS YEAR,
DONALD TRUMP WILL BE THE MOST
VALUABLE PLAYER FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY BECAUSE HE HAS
NOMINATED CANDIDATES IN GEORGIA,
IN ARIZONA, IN PENNSYLVANIA, WHO
ARE VULNERABLE TO DEMOCRATS,
EVEN IN A VERY DIFFICULT YEAR.
AND SO I'M SURE THERE ARE A LOT
OF REPUBLICANS WHO HAVE SOME
HEARTBURN ABOUT THAT.
>> DAVID, CONGRESS HAS ACTUALLY
BEEN DOING STUFF, HAVE YOU
NOTICED?
>> YEAH, IT IS WEIRD.
>> THEY HAVE ACHIEVED SOME
THINGS, IN A BIPARTISAN FASHION
NO LESS.
IS THIS REAL LIFE?
>> WELL, IT IS FOR THE PEOPLE
LIKE THE -- PEOPLE WHO BENEFIT
FROM THE BURN PIT BILL.
IT IS REAL LIFE FOR THEM.
AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT WE SHOULD
KEEP FOCUSED ON, BUT, YOU KNOW,
JOE BIDEN HAS BEEN ATTACKED AND
RIDICULED BY A LOT OF PEOPLE FOR
HIS BELIEF THAT PERHAPS THERE
COULD BE BIPARTISAN ACTION ON A
SERIES OF THINGS.
WELL, NOW THAT IS COMING TO
FRUITION AND, YOU KNOW, THE
QUESTION IS WHETHER THIS WILL BE
A BENEFIT OR NOT.
>> LOOKING AT THIS LIST, THE
CHIPS ACT, INFRASTRUCTURE,
POSTAL REFORM, THE BURN PIT, THE
PACK ACT, EMMETT TILL
ANTI-LYNCHING LAW, ON AND ON AND
ON, SOME MAJOR BIPARTISAN
ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
HOW COME YOU THINK THIS HAS NOT
BENEFITED JOE BIDEN IN THE
POLLS?
IT SHOWS YOU CAN GOVERN FROM THE
CENTER, THERE IS SOME INDICATION
OF PROGRESS, BUT HE'S UNDER 40%.
WHERE IS THAT DISCONNECT?
>> I THINK THERE ARE THREE
REASONS FOR IT.
THE FIRST IS THE AFOREMENTIONED
ECONOMY, THE FACT THAT WE HAVE
THIS HUGE PROBLEM WITH INFLATION
HAS COLORED PEOPLE'S ATTITUDES
ABOUT THE DIRECTION OF THE
COUNTRY.
THE SECOND IS HE HIMSELF AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION SET SUCH HIGH
EXPECTATIONS, THE NEW NEW DEAL,
THE NEW FDR AND SO ON, THAT
REALLY SIZABLE ACCOMPLISHMENTS
NOW SEEM LIKE COMPROMISES THAT
ARE LESS THAN THEY REALLY ARE.
SO HE'S DONE HIMSELF -- AND THE
THIRD, JOHN, IS JUST
PERFORMATIVE.
IT IS NOT ABOUT PERFORMANCE IN
OFFICE.
IT IS ABOUT PERFORMANCE IN FRONT
OF THE CAMERA.
AND, YOU KNOW, THE PRESIDENT IS
NOT STELLAR IN FRONT OF CAMERAS
NOW.
HE APPEARS OLD TO A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
THAT HAS HURT HIM.
BUT THE FACT IS THE RECORD IS
REALLY, REALLY IMPRESSIVE.
>> DEBATE IN THE -- IN A NEW
YORK HOUSE RACE LAST NIGHT THAT
HAD AN INCREDIBLY INTERESTING
MOMENT.
IT WAS HOSTED BY THE WAY THERE,
DEAR FRIEND OF THE SHOW, ERROL
LOUIS, AND THIS IS WHAT HAPPENED
WHEN THE CANDIDATES WERE ASKED
IF JOE BIDEN SHOULD RUN FOR
RE-ELECTION.
>> SHOULD PRESIDENT BIDEN RUN
AGAIN IN 2024?
>> YES.
>> MR. NADLER?
>> TOO EARLY TO SAY.
DOESN'T SERVE THE PURPOSE OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY TO DEAL WITH
THAT UNTIL AFTER THE MIDTERMS.
>> MISS MALONEY?
>> I DON'T BELIEVE HE'S RUNNING
FOR RE-ELECTION.
>> MIC DROP.
>> JOHN KING, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> INTERESTING TO ME THAT THE
YOUNGER CANDIDATE, THE NEXT
GENERATION DEMOCRAT TRYING TO
BREAKTHROUGH IS THE ONE WHO SAID
YES.
BECAUSE THAT IS THE -- THAT IS
THE PIECE OF THE PARTY THAT
WOULD LIKE GENERATIONAL CHANGE.
THEY WOULD LIKE MR. NADLER AND
CONGRESSWOMAN MALONEY TO STEP
ASIDE AS WELL.
THERE IS THIS FESTERING ENERGY
AMONG YOUNGER -- ESPECIALLY
PROGRESSIVE SIDE OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, SAYING PLEASE
GET OUT OF THE WAY, NO
DISRESPECT, THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE, WE WANT OUR GENERATION
TO COME FORWARD.
JERRY NADLER IS RIGHT.
THIS IS A CONVERSATION BEST PUT
OFF UNTIL AFTER THE MIDTERMS TO
DAVID'S POINT ABOUT COMMU
COMMUNICCOMMU
COMMUNICATING.
YOU HAD CONGRESSMAN PHILIPS OF
MINNESOTA SAY LAST WEEK HE
DIDN'T THINK BIDEN SHOULD RUN.
NOW YOU HAVE THIS COMING UP IN A
DEBATE IN NEW YORK.
IT WILL BE PART OF THE
DEMOCRATIC CONVERSATION.
I'VE BEEN AT THIS A LONG TIME.
DAVID WAS A REPORTER BEFORE HE
WAS A STRATEGIST.
DEMOCRATS OFTEN HAVE TROUBLE
COMMUNICATING AND KEEPING THEIR
FOCUS.
THE INFIGHTING, THE INFIGHTING
IS ONE OF THE THINGS THAT HAS
UNDERMINED THEM.
THAT LIST YOU SHOWED, JOHN,
THINK ABOUT THE LACK OF THE --
THE LACK OF ABILITY IN
WASHINGTON TO GET THINGS DONE IN
RECENT YEARS BECAUSE OF
POLARIZATION.
IT IS AN IMPRESSIVE LIST.
BUT DEMOCRATS PROMISED THE MOON,
STARS AND BEYOND WHEN THEY WON
THOSE TWO GEORGIA SENATE SEATS.
THEY DELIVERED MAYBE JUST THE
MOON HERE AND STILL A LOT OF
ANXIETY IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
ALSO HARD TO BREAKTHROUGH TO
VOTERS IN A TIME THEY'RE
EXHAUSTED, AFTER COVID AND THEN
GETTING -- STILL IN COVID, AND
THEN GETTING HIT WITH INFLATION.
>> THERE IS YOUR MESSAGE.
THE MOON IS GOOD.
>> WE HAVE THE MOON.
DON'T WORRY ABOUT THE STARS.
I WANT TO RETURN, THOUGH, AND
GET YOUR TAKE ON THE COMMENT,
BECAUSE IT SEEMED LIKE A CLASSIC
WASHINGTON GAFFE, TELLING THE
TRUTH OUT LOUD UNINTENTIONALLY.
>> I HAVE NO IDEA WHY SHE DID
THAT.
MAYBE SHE FELT SHE WAS
IDENTIFYING HERSELF WITH THE
YOUNGER VOTERS WHO WANT OLDER
POLITICIANS TO MOVE ON.
BUT SHE'S UP IN YEARS HERSELF.
I'M NOT SURE THAT WAS A VERY
HELPFUL MESSAGE.
>> CERTAINLY NOT FOR THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
GENTLEMEN, JOHN KING, DAVID
AXELROD, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.